et pour en parler nous recevons à
monsieur jacques amyot gilet jaune
bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau alors on a vu un cet acte 64
risque d'être un petit peu compliqué
puisque la préfecture de police donc
interdit certaines zones de ce pack
cortège parisien
quelles sont les raisons à votre avis
ballet raison ce sont toujours les mêmes
on ne nous ne sommes pas entendus ils
veulent nous mettre dans des zones de
paris très très loin des lieux de
pouvoir pour qu'on puisse pas être vu ni
entendu monsieur macron s'est targué de
dire que nous n'étions pas dans une
digue dans une dictature dans une
démocratie on va pouvoir la mettre à
l'épreuve puisque on a quand même là la
liberté de pouvoir manifester et de
circuler ben on va pouvoir voir ça cet
après midi et ce mouvement des idées
j'ai je vous savez maintenant à plus
d'un an et demi puis on l'a vu un ces
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites depuis plusieurs semaines
qu'ils sont à présent tu
on a l'impression qu'il ya deux poids
deux mesures concernant vos cortège on
le voit bien et les les manifestants
contre la réforme des retraites se
déplace assez facilement
alors que les jets les jeunes ont
beaucoup plus de mal comment ça
s'explique je ne sais pas on a vu la
manifestation des pompiers qui a été
très très durs très très violente
moi j'ai l'image qui qui n'arrête pas de
tourner en boucle dans ma tête de ce
commandement pompiers sur ce camion à
eau se prenant une balle de l bd dans la
tête alors qu'il n'y avait aucune
dangerosité dans ses gestes dans dans sa
posture donc pourquoi deux poids deux
mesures je ne sais pas est-ce que
c'est le fait aussi que nous soyons
depuis 14 15 mois dans la rue maintenant
ça ça peut venir de là je ne sais pas
est ce qu'il ya des ententes avec les
syndicats et la préfecture
je sais pas du tout le mot d'ordre
aujourd'hui c'est liberté égalité
fraternité
vous êtes cette manifestation comment
est-ce que vous appréhendez 7 cette
journée basée parlait justement de ces
violences que l'on a vu à la semaine
dernière entre les forces de l'ordre et
les pompiers qui font partie finalement
du du même ministère et qui voilà qui
arrive à se battre au final on
appréhende forcément parce que ça fait
quatorze mois qu'on voit alors autant il
y en a certains qui se sont très bien
passés mais on sait pourquoi quand on va
dans une manifestation et que la
préfecture mais en nombre les forces de
l'ordre nous encadrant comme des
prisonniers dans une cour carcéral ce
qu'on appelle des nas mobile bah c'est
sûr que là il y aura pas de débordements
ni quoi que ce soit mais on se sent
vraiment oppressé et se sont fins et la
préfecture les forces de l'ordre qui
mène la manifestation une manifestation
à partir aux manifestants et en plus on
nous met dans des quartiers on est
complètement occulté par les lieux de
pouvoir nous ce qu'on veut vraiment
c'est le pouvoir se faire entendre par
les sénateurs les députés les ministres
etc
donc c'est vraiment en passant devant
ces institutions dans ces institutions
pardon devant ces lieux de pouvoir est
ce que quand vous discutez avec
avec vos collègues avec vos avis qui
sont présents justement dans ces
manifestants de manifestations est ce
qu'il n'ya pas une sorte de lassitude
aussi qui vous gagne
avec le temps 64e samedi consécutif de
mobilisation et le gouvernement reste
sourd face justement face avant il n'y a
pas de lassitude et de découragement
après il y en a qui qui ont peur de la
forte répression dont ont fait preuve
ses skis mais le nombre moins important
de manifestants aujourd'hui donc c'est
ça c'est ça mais après je peux vous
assurer qu'il y en a beaucoup à qui je
parle et leurs fins de mois sont
toujours aussi difficiles même pire
qu'avant et je trouve qu'avec les
violences policières aussi on s'éloigne
du sujet principal c'est qu'on est tous
sortis dans la rue pour un pour
apprendre à mieux vivre pour pour
vraiment notre pouvoir d'achat et pour
pour le futur de nos enfants parce que
là on voit que le futur de nos enfants
il va être catastrophique
les revendications sont les mêmes ou est
ce que l on a évolué c'est toujours les
mêmes après il y en a d'autres qui sont
venus se greffer mais le coeur ça reste
le pouvoir d'achat après effectivement
les retraites sont venus se greffer
comme on l'est tous les tous les corps
de métiers que ce soit les pompiers que
ce soit les enseignants que ça soit les
infirmiers tout ça est venue se greffer
mais le coeur ça reste le pouvoir
d'achat un mieux vivre un meilleur
avenir très bien en tout cas merci
beaucoup jacques mignaux d'avoir répondu
à nouveau à la question je rappelle que
vous êtes gilet jaune
merci merci à vous